(cheerful music)
- Hi Drew.
My name is Simone and I am in my hometown
of Baltimore, Maryland.
I love Baltimore because
it has so much history,
so much beauty, but the
thing I love most here
is the food scene.
I'm a food blogger here in the area,
so I post all the best eats
and drinks in Baltimore.
So I want to show you around
to several of Baltimore's
most fun and exciting
and delicious food destinations.
First stop is Belvedere Square Market.
Say hello to my friends
at Neopol Savory Smokery.
In general, they sell all
kinds of smoked goods,
but Neopol sells my favorite
sandwich in Baltimore,
their salmon BLT
and their famous New
Zealand smoked mussels.
These are a must try here in Baltimore.
For dessert, ice cream from
Prigel Family Creamery.
Mandy here is going to help us out.
They are a family owned creamery
right beside of Belvedere Square,
and they have a farm out in the county,
but they make their ice
cream fresh every day.
My cameraman here got
their strawberry ice cream
with sprinkles and a cherry on top.
Last stop at Belvedere Square
Market is Tasha Flowers.
I come to Tasha to get my
bouquets for my living room,
kitchen, bedroom for the week.
- So I'm going to grab
this Asiatic lily here
because look at that.
- Yes.
- It is perfectly opened.
- That's just a little peak
of Belvedere Square Market.
Now moving onto our second stop.
Welcome to chat hour at
Good Neighbor Coffee Shop.
We'll have some very creative appetizers,
great conversation.
So amazing.
Our third stop is here on the water.
Welcome to the Baltimore
Water Taxi sunset cruise.
Here, you bring your
favorite snacks and drinks
and cruise along the inner harbor,
watching the sun go down
and just the beautiful
skyline of Baltimore.
Well Drew,
that's just a small look at my
beautiful city of Baltimore.
I hope you loved it as much as I do,
and I hope to see you here soon.
Bye.